scène vous êtes avec nous comment ça se
passe de l'autre côté on vient de le
voir du côté de david quelques
débordements à noter un on a vu
effectivement on ira c'est la même chose
ici nous sommes en tête de cortège où
les gilet jaune ont pris la tête du
cortège on les a suivis depuis le début
de ce rassemblement qui a eu lieu à
partir de 10 heures qui a traversé à
paris pour se retrouver place de la
république là on en tête de cortège
s'est arrêté à approuver un bon moment
il ya eu des lancements de bombes
lacrymogènes par les forces de l'ordre
comme vous le pouvoir juste derrière moi
les forces de l'ordre de retourner un
petit peu en arrière au milieu du
cortège où se trouve david où les
tensions sont beaucoup plus palpable ici
nous sommes avec les gilet jaune et
gilet jaune qui sont bien déterminés à
descendre dans la rue deux ans et demi
après leur première manifestation
souvenez-vous les mêmes revendications
je vous propose d'en écouter certains
d'eux on veut un retour de vraie
démocratie c'est à dire c'est le peuple
qui décide des mousses kratos est pas
comme on entend république à l'heure
actuelle qui est un système on a besoin
aussi d'un de pouvoir vivre quand on vit
avec moins de 900 euros on peut pas pas
on peut pas vivre même avec 1200 euros
c'est très dur de vivre en région
parisienne ou même ailleurs donc c'est
ça qui est compliqué des salaires
mirobolants
c'est parce qu'on demande 1 c'est
vraiment vivre sérieusement alors déjà
je suis restaurateur est donc pour moi
il était encore plus important de
montrer notre détermination à faire
changer ce système est aujourd'hui le
1er mai c'est une convergence des luttes
donc on essaye d'être là je pense que
c'était une journée importante je savais
qu'ils allaient avoir du monde
aujourd'hui donc j'en profitais pour
fermer mon restaurant et venir
manifester parce que pour l'avenir de
nos enfants je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui manifester notre
mécontentement sur les mesures
sanitaires et sur sur tout ce qui peut
exister mais levait à malversations
voilà on est ni des casseurs ni des
malfrats ni des moins que rien et c
on a toujours les mêmes revendications
quand vous regardez le prix de l'essence
aujourd'hui va finalement rien n'a
changé elle est même encore plus cher
que quand on a les prix quand on avait
pris la rue en novembre 2018 donc bah
voilà rien n'a changé ça ne fait
qu'empirer
donc on est là on est toujours là alors
vous l'avez compris les mêmes
revendications en irak depuis le début
les jeunes sont décidés à redire encore
une fois qu'ils veulent
ou plus de justice sociale il demande au
gouvernement de prendre en considération
ces mêmes revendications qu'il ya deux
ans et demi convergence des luttes
aujourd'hui avec pas mal d'associations
et pas mal de syndicats qui sont
descendus dans la rue les gilet jaune
font partie de ces manifestants juste
derrière moi comment on peut voir sur la
place voltaire déjà un nouveau
rassemblement les jeunes qui ont pris la
tête de ce cortège et puis bien sûr nous
allons les rejoindre pour suivre cette
manifestation pour le moment le calme
est revenu mais la tension reste assez
palpable pour cette manifestation du 1er
mai merci à bassam on reste de toute
façon avec vous